an increasingly confident China
[Music]
an incumbent superpower and a clash of
values embodied by pro-democracy
protests in Hong Kong disagreement on
Hong Kong as well as on trade and
technology existed long before the
pandemic but experts say coronavirus has
intensified the us-china standoff
raising the risk of what some see as a
new cold war we might recognize Hong
Kong as kind of the new Berlin but
whether Hong Kong is the West on it is
Berlin it's hard to say or guarantee but
it really depends on how we can stand up
and fight back in the UK a sense of
normality as lockdown rules are eased
but out of the sunshine a serious
rethink is expected of UK policy on
China also on the horizon a struggle for
all states to unite or to accept the
will of the strongest Britain's
interests and influence extend far
beyond its source its foreign policy
like other liberal democracies is based
on overseas alliances and on an
international system of agreements and
global institutions and yet it was the
instinct of all nations including in
Europe to close their borders
unilaterally and turn inwards when the
pandemic struck this former top diplomat
says the pandemic has sharpened
rivalries at a time when countries need
to work together we are at one of those
watershed moments a bit like after the
Second World War I think what we risk is
a cut is a world fractured in two
spheres of influence again clearly a
Chinese sphere and American sphere and
European sphere perhaps rather weaker
China's standing firm despite mounting
US pressure do you think the pandemic
could actually increase the risk of the
tensions between the US and China
ESCA
perhaps even to war I hope not I hope
the Cold War would not become a hot war
no I think Chinese leaders keep continue
to stress US and China should not be
couple we have a lot to learn and a
benefit for our continued engagement
Britain will certainly be seeking unity
over division in this post pandemic
world but not at any cost
Deborah Haynes Sky News